what is that i don't like it
[Music]
i don't like it at all
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones
it's the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings and today we're joined
by elizabeth olsen
she's an actress whose work includes
everything from acclaimed indies like
wind river and ingram goes west to the
marvel cinematic universe and the mega
hit show wand division which of course
is currently streaming on disney plus
elizabeth olsen welcome to the show
thanks for having me
and long overdue if you ask me we got
like a little taste with the fridge tour
but now it's the real deal
yeah i know that you're an adventurous
eater how are you around the spicy stuff
i don't want to be too bold about like
how spicy i like my food but i
i think i'm okay under promise over
deliver
yeah i think well possibly i could also
just be like
right on with the under promise
these are great wings by the way and i
don't even know how long ago they were
made because i'd assume you guys prep
them probably
a bit ago shout out to dom shout out to
you're pretty good holding the show
together
[Music]
that's very good so wanda vision is this
genre warping time traveling show that
parodies different decades and classic
television
and then i saw in your interview on
table manners you were talking about how
this is like shooting a six
hour project with the same time and
budget constraints of a two-hour film
yeah what does that actually feel like
or look like in practice i
love all different types of actors
sometimes people come to work and they
like had a great idea
when they were sleeping and so now we
have to rearrange
like lines and stuff for a scene and
that takes up a lot of time and we
didn't have that time so it was
it was like chaos and sometimes we had
to do multiple decades
and a day so like wigs i'm always like
in a bald cat basically so like wigs are
just constantly flying on and off and
katherine hot and i just like doing
vocal warm-ups trying to remember what
decade we're in
and it was chaotic but it was fun and we
had a good time it was like truly joyful
and then did you have a favorite wand
division easter egg because speaking of
catherine han i read that like the house
that she's in
is the actual literal like bewitched
house it is
yeah um i i learn about easter eggs
when people point them out so the one
that i learned about that i thought was
really great was a
like the the there's a wine bottle
that's poured and the first episode in
the 50s episode
and it's in french but i think it
translated to something like
oh god i can't say like family
relationship or no but like
it's like it's like a house of madness
or something like that that's
a reference to house of m and that's
just like our like brilliant prop guy
being cute and
putting in those things i think on like
just he just thinks of them
it's a pretty color it's like a peruvian
vibe kind of okay
so i'm curious how does acting and
producing simultaneously on a project
like sorry for your loss
how does it affect how you look at the
equilibrium between
art and commerce like does actually
being accountable to the financing
and all that encapsulates a production
does it shift your perspective
as a creative the understanding
of the ridiculous amount of money that
goes into things and that people should
like really
care and be kind and good like in those
situations because
it you should be like ashamed of
yourself if you show up to work and you
know
like every everything that the heads of
department had to go through and all the
preparation and
all the time and energy and approval and
then to like show up and not know what
you're doing i think it's just really
disrespectful and rude and
um i think i've already had the
mentality
uh i loved producing everything from
creating a crew
to like sound mixing and color
corrections i just really enjoyed that
yeah yeah a lot going on yeah speaking
of yes are you ready to move on here to
the next wing
yes it's a clear sauce well you know
until you shake it up
okay it's like it's activated okay oh oh
i like that word
oh cool
[Music]
it looks peppery pepper bomb this one
kind of stuff guys i'm actually getting
nervous but i'm not
i'm like panicking inside my chest right
now it's like waiting for it to scare me
that's peppery there you feel that one
it's like a leap from here yeah
yeah i know that you did a semester at
the moscow art theater school
do you have like a preference or a
method that you think
is more effective between the
stanislavski art of experiencing versus
the chekhov organic performance
that's so funny well so when i went to
the moscow art theater school
they believed that they continued the
stanislavski training like it didn't
stop and die with him
it's a very strange program for an
american first semester it was very
different
but it was an amazing experience i like
how to do [ __ ] that i like wasn't you
know the atlantic theater company that
would like roll their eyes if you like
do like sense memory [ __ ] it's just i
don't know it's very funny going to an
acting school
i went going to multiple acting schools
because everyone just makes fun of
one another yeah well what do you think
is like the most bizarre unique acting
exercise that you've ever done as part
of like a conservatory program
i just like have a memory
there's a oh oh i have a good one it's
called fitzmorris work
and it's a vocal technique
and it basically is putting yourself in
positions where your body
like vibrates so like um holding like
versions of like
yoga poses or like you're on your back
like holding your legs in ways and
you're like body's supposed to vibrate
and then you're supposed to let your
voice
like respond to that vibration and so
everyone just
um is in a room basically making orgasm
sounds
and it's and then some people like have
like huge breakdowns
um from like the release
acting school's weird
i still have like a tingle but i'm not
mad at myself
yet
[Music]
i'm smokey
[Music]
that's like a sweetness to it into a
smoke and a sweetness
we're calling it the unofficial official
sauce of summer you know that's kind of
like a
that's a slow cooked meat situation or
like a
grilled veggie situation yeah like with
some like pulled
meats or something i can i can that's
fine
i'm like okay fine
i'm just like getting so anxious right
now and i wish i weren't
so you have a reputation for being
obsessive about your prep work and i've
never heard an actress
so funny really talk about the
auditioning process in such glowing
terms like you do i think most of your
peers would describe that as like the
worst part of the business
why do you get joy out of auditioning a
few things
there's something really special about
having ownership of a character
that no one else has an opinion on yet
and it's a kind of like a nice moment
for an actor i think
and also the it's like an absurd
situation it's very funny it's a very
like to be in an audition did you ever
go on auditions or you ever
do actor stuff well i don't act but one
time when they were like rebooting trl
like when mtv was rebooting trl yeah
they had me go in there and like that
old like time square studio
and like stand on a thing and like and
were there other people waiting for
their
turn yeah other people waiting and then
like the big long table with like all
the people not making any sort of
like uh no poker faces
yeah exactly all the way through and
then just be like and when we come back
we're giving away two tickets the mtv
beach house you don't want to miss it
trl be right back just doing a bunch of
those things did you want to get the job
no so that's my only real experience
okay now also when i get the opportunity
to audition first off i hate taped
auditions they feel so
stupid but when i get to go and audition
which
doesn't happen that often but i enjoy it
when it does
it's it's like a day where you're gonna
do your job
that you like to do apparently i don't
know so that's how i feel about
it
[Music]
this ginger goat guy those looking me
straight in the eye
[Music]
like tropical there is a little
pineapple on that one
the ginger ginger all right elizabeth
also we have a recurring segment on our
show called explain that graham where do
a deep dive on our guest instagram pull
interesting pictures that need more
context
challenging for you though since you've
exiled yourself from social media
entirely i did how'd you do it
you can go to the gettys you know we
have a login and everything okay
so we do have a workaround but i'm
curious like what is your internal math
on like the cost-benefit analysis of
having instagram
i think the benefit is for true projects
that are
hard to verbalize
um or like get out not verbally but how
it's not hard to verbalize but how hard
to like
put out the word out in the world i
think it's a great benefit
and i think everything else is
detrimental that makes sense
to me well let's dive into the wires
shall we
you once described you encapsulated your
experiences
at comic con is always moving can you
unpackage that
oh that was that's like a very nice
thing of me to have said
i i think they're
i they are they surprised me so i
my first comic con where you like sit
and sign things
i was really not looking forward to it
and i thought it was like kind of a
strange position to put yourself in like
a vulnerable
place where you like meet a bunch of
strangers
what i loved about it is it was this
place that like people were like
so kind to one another they were all
there gathered for the same thing that
they love
and i thought that was moving
that yeah i think any kind of thing that
brings people together that way i think
is
lovely in the world we're just kind of
fishing for a fashion show
hijinks story and all of your
experiences like have you
ever witnessed like a public temper
tantrum from somebody expecting a front
row seat and didn't get one or is it
i was part of one of the craziest
big things i had ever seen and i'm not
gonna name
the design company it was
the security guard of like the person
who ran the whole company
not like designer
was assaulting naomi watts
to make her move like not be there
and it was and jessica chastain was like
like elbowing in and like got like got
in the security guy's face and like
other security guys
came and then like the lights went down
the man who owned the company was there
and
everyone acted like nothing had just
happened it was
so bizarre i it was so buzz it was
very weird
i'm salivating so hard right now
uh-oh sugar juice isn't that it's too
lag
yeah okay fine
i knew that that was a bad idea so in
addition to today's flight of wings i've
seen you eating gourmet cheeses with
bradley
and then of course chatting with jessie
ware and her mom over lebanese lamb
on table manners you know even for
somebody who's sworn off social media
you do seem to have your fingers on the
pulse of the internet a little bit
oh where does that impulse oh my god i
if i could like capture that and send it
to all my friends
i thank you
i've got my finger on the pulse my
friends really have their finger on the
pulse though you made wild boar ragu
with eric repair i did and i've seen you
say that you're star struck by tom
colicchio what do you think is
this one cookbook that everyone should
every home chef should have in their
kitchen
i just got the old buco cookbook which
has
recipes from all their different chefs
throughout the years just to also learn
about the restaurant if you're
an ibuko fan you're you're an el bucco
stan
i'm an elbuko stan does that mean i
troll them and want to like hurt them
no no no like the way that you bleed
dodger blue yeah
yeah yeah like you're more than a fan
yes ill buco
i'm 32 and i have spent
like half my birthdays on this planet at
ilbucco
well then as i guess it's only right
that you got the cookbook are you ready
to move on
yes i am elizabeth olsen to the next one
here you're doing great by the way this
is
hotter than l in the seven spot shout
out my friend l
fun um okay that's a
terrifying image is that a brain or a
heart
[Music]
that's a good question actually like are
they telling us something
hmm
that one like just like really wants to
like surprise you up front
right make sure that you get ready
because there's even a little bit coming
behind that
okay but it really like gets you
oh i see so mechanically what was the
most challenging aspect in shooting a
film like silent house which was meant
to appear as one
singular long tape since it's so long
behind me that was
one of the worst experiences of my life
that was awful to have to for the
majority of a horror movie
be in like tears screaming crawling on a
floor
i had bruises all over my legs i got a
sinus infection from
all of the tears because i always have
snot before tears
right now and it was just brutal
if that was the first movie i'd gotten i
would have gone back to theater
i wouldn't want to do another movie can
you give us one production
snafu or stroke of bad luck on the set
of ingrid goes west i've heard you
described yourself as shocked by how
well it came out
oh my god yeah where should we start um
uh one of the locations that aubrey
plaza
had who's a great guest on this had to
be sitting on a floor crying
wasn't secured so when they got there
there were squatters and human feces
so they had to clean that and then while
everyone was in hazmat suits
aubrey was just like laying on that
floor
i mean our director ran into a glass
wall and had to go to the hospital
we had a fire we had to evacuate but we
couldn't evacuate until we were sure we
were going to get our insurance
money it was crazy logistical nightmare
it was a crazy one
and matt spicer did an amazing job i was
truly
i loved watching that movie at sundance
because i was just like
so confused how we did it this is like a
full back
of the face
situation and it is making me
tear i guess and sweat
welcome to the hot ones experience it's
a great idea you guys this is a great
concept and that's why it's such a great
show to watch
[Music]
reputation for this one precedes it a
little bit okay
wow
i don't even like that yeah nobody does
like at least the other ones were like
we're kind to like have nice flavors but
that was just that's just like offensive
it's just like there's like not even joy
to it it's just like they're trying to
scare people and make their
shining moment on this show how do you
guys find out oh my god
underneath my tongue that's really weird
and then this is just where i'll say be
careful around your eyes you know
because sometimes maybe you'll get like
a little sweat around your face
right no i'll just use the napkin oh my
god i've never had spice underneath my
tongue before
what is that i don't like it
i don't like it at all is there an
inspiration from your travels that
you've brought
into your life whether it's a design
detail that you brought into your home
or a dish that you've added to your
repertoire
yes home garden is
um very reflective of a place i've been
to in tuscany
like lots of purples and lavender and
rosemary's and
those kinds of flowers that grow wild
love taking care of my plants
i have a beautiful blueberry two plants
that are doing
brilliantly this year i'm okay i'm okay
that
really freaked me out i still got all
the tingles
um but it calmed itself and i
kind of want some of this because it's
so cold it looks so
refreshing you know
yeah it didn't defend me it's fine there
we go there we go all right this next
one
is the scorpion disco okay
[Music]
i got that one in my teeth here i'll do
this
aubry famously snorted milk you know i
saw that she did a brilliant job
i haven't done the no i haven't gotten
the nose feeling yet i just had a visual
memory of are you
it's so good it's gone
the towelette corner okay fine it passed
it wasn't as
the dot once you get through the bomb
yeah everything in life becomes a little
bit easier
so you seem to have such a cheerful
taste in entertainment for your money
when you think about
the best your favorite musicals of all
time what's the first title that comes
to mind
the first one that's in your head right
now oklahoma
why oklahoma probably because it's like
an easy thing to remember
um i watched that movie all the time as
a kid i watched those old movies
just non-stop so oklahoma what's a piece
of classic cinema
the first title that pops into your
brain when you think about the perfect
movie for our audience to watch tonight
a night in with a bottle of wine the
conformist
love the conformist great beautiful
beautiful visuals
it's beautiful and then finally is there
a project of
yours maybe uh under the radar project
that makes you feel the most sentimental
when fans bring it up to you when they
see you on the street
you know what no one ever talks about
because they don't need to
is um i saw the light i just really that
was a special experience
and we had a great crew and a lot of fun
making it
but we didn't you know whatever didn't
really do that well it's fine
okay oh right we do this
what does a dab look like
okay is that it does that veggie dab
that was moving
that looks great fine that looks great
okay this little veggie top
it's not a shy dab but it's a dab cheers
elizabeth
what a ride this has been great thank
you thank you
[Music]
it did okay you did okay you did beyond
okay you did amazing
and thankfully we're at the final act of
this bizarre
chicken wing circus show and just one
more hurdle standing between you and the
finish line
i'm curious how does your personal
mantra
of try and beat your last best score fit
how you're feeling right now
like do you see yourself trying to scale
even higher peaks on spice mountain or
is this experience been enough for you
you know what you know how when before
we i don't think we were rolling but
when we when i came in here
and you said how do i feel about spices
and i said at a restaurant they asked me
do i want my food spicy one to ten i
always say five
i would maybe play with that number a
bit more now
that's how i feel and i think that
because i think i'm
okay no you are beyond okay you know
i don't know but we'll have to wait you
know to see your body how i really feel
you know what it's like you've seen it
through elizabeth olsen
taking on the hot ones gauntlet and
living to tell the tale
and now elizabeth olsen there's nothing
left to do but roll out the red carpet
for you
this camera this camera this camera let
the people know what you have going on
in your life
oh um well
i'm in new york city and
is did you say there is one over there
there's another one yeah
in the cut right there oh i see you i
see you
and um i'm i'm just enjoying
being here and not in los angeles where
i usually live
and i just had some hot wings that are
kind of living on parts of my face
and but i'm feeling okay i feel um
i feel brave i feel strong and
um like i can conquer hot wings
no argument here
thank you thank you thank you
[Applause]
does this help the mustache burn just
time
time here right right right it'll just
be here thank you
thank you did you have a good time i had
a great time that was fabulous
and i love chicken wings and those were
delicious and some of them are really
loved
hey what's going on everybody this is
sean evans checking in with a very
important psa
if you've kept up with all things hot
ones you know that at the end of last
year we partnered with common threads
a charity that provides cooking classes
and healthy meals to families in need
and while we have the impossible good
fortune of being able
to eat scorching hot chicken wings with
celebrities every single week
there are kids across the country who
lack the basic nutrition they need to be
healthy happy and energized to learn
that's where we need your help right now
we're working towards the goal of
raising 50
000 that common threads can continue to
provide cooking classes and groceries to
families in need
as well as professional development for
educators and then nutritional education
for healthcare providers and patients
our buddy george moats kicked off this
fundraising campaign by cooking
cheeseburgers with his son mac
great video if you haven't seen it today
i'm sharing a link right here on the
screen below me to help work towards our
goal so if you can donate anything
donate anything at all
please do it all goes to the common
threads programming goals
hot ones stinging celebrities helping
the kids
please donate if you can